a lancha e aí galera do planalto com
vocês eu queria falar nela é natal rio
grande do norte está sexta-feira em mim
abandonar o avião agora já aceita pela
troca de avião sexta-feira dia 24 de
março
andei show na arena das dunas às 21
horas vai entender melhor o maior show
de natal já 2678 tem show em portugal
olha que massa em 16 em ponto tas 78
esboçou a minha internacional agora quer
fazer cair na pobreza pensa não vai ter
ninguém já falei a eles os seus próximos
shows você quer comprar ingresso e nesse
site que está aparecendo aqui na tela
tem muito lá no site quem quiser olhar
para ver se está a instalar poder em
porto velho tem rio branco no acre em
cuiabá tem vários lugares olha o site é
não estão no estudo mais tudo mais fácil
o tempo inclusive crianças em deus muito
obrigado também o resto de minha vida
inteira em escola pública e tem mais de
faísca já não terá só do rio mas quando
o pobre quando champanhe na diretoria
por exemplo a escola enrique mita
começam de manhã na sala chega o dia do
vau java diretoria galera já fica -
apontada na escola do rio quando mandei
pra diretoria sala já dá aquela calado
clima já fica mais intenso chegando a
diretoria conversa com o diretor e leva
advertência no dia só vai pra escola se
a mãe for lá a mãe fica desapontada
jorge eu não acredito que é pela segunda
vez em três anos já por isso é uma pena
que nem a diretoria nem jeito quer
chegar em árvore que caiu ao mar se usa
de assim não foi esse o menino quando
keita mãe não fui eu mas mãe de jorge
não quer ouvir nada que sim playstation
3 dias jean e desculpas oradores falando
coisas devem ser elas vezes enfim tomar
medidas drásticas sempre intenso em seu
nome e o pólo na diretoria com uma faca
a diretoria a sala todo o país aqui e
é escola pública paixão meu pior do que
ser mandado para diretoria é alguém vir
me chamar para diretor ea emel amiga ea
sala onde só por deus perdoa a escola de
pobre no pergunto eu eu o que foi que eu
fiz é esse mas fui muito papo na
diretoria ela não fica falando que ela
vai proibir o que ela vai fazer olhar
que o menino ia chegar só tem uma frase
que acaba com a vida da criança acaba
pressão psicológica me levar pra cá
chegar em casa falou assim ah quando seu
pai chegar você vai ver que acabou
acabou a minha vida com a boca eu fazia
o cálculo do meu tamanho tamanho meu pai
falou 'vou morrer teza eu vou ligar meu
pai paul e paetê seu e vai demorar pra
mim pra casa vai vai não está chegando
já né e coisa boa é papai casa total
chegando na escola chega bons contatos
cota tranqüilo claro está não só beba
não longe de mim um enorme problema nós
nessas coisas de cabeça tranquila mas a
mãe que está sem medo é não ficar
falando muita besteira
papai e mamãe não esqueceu do pai mãe
agora é só negar disso de detenção de
escola diretor inventando inventando as
coisas longe nada vez mais saber de ser
pai eu só queria dizer uma coisa te amo
mais que tudo no universo e as estrelas
não quis falar mesmo se não é forçado
não quis falar por si ou por que eu eu
nunca se sabe quando é que até quando a
gente vai ter um pai né nem e nem até
quando você vai ter um filho por isso
que é bom já está sempre trocando suas
palavras bonito que vai que perde o
filho ea última posição fez foi dar um
avanço nele né um exemplo por altas e
pensando pensando alto melhor melhor não
né
o negócio de que violência não melhor é
aceitar o zeus qualquer coisa que que vê
porventura acontecer um dia a que eu
nunca aconteceu nada não
bom pai te amo você tá muito o lanche do
rico mas doía tanto que ninguém anso 500
é o de campeã suquinho pra você está em
caixinha poço que encaixa meta de sua
pasta carne hoje que já é caxias vem sul
que agora em caixa caso do unitri dormir
nu como substância ocasiões do populacho
conhecimento na creche pedreiro já
escola pública da holanda japão o creme
crack com doce leite conhece carro
nescau tinha nem leite era só o nescau
com água ea leste com o nescau toma um
curso com o exemplo bem preparado né
como os higienizados e pessoal eles mas
como esses alimentos podem nutrir tanto
uma criança citam são alimentos de tão
pouca taxa de carboidratos e proteínas
focada a quantidade meu amigo porque era
creme craque um dos maiores que comer 45
era leite começa uma nova bebida dez
copos com escova na comida no mínimo por
baixo 15 prata o que paga as técnicas
para pegar mais comida primeiro sentar
na fila normal e caminhando num meu
lanche por favor depois sentar na frente
de novo aqui no tumulto você botar uma
só mão assim eu vou pegar entendeu o
irmãozinho alternado a xata piloto da
fila pelo tumulto acabou com a mão
esquerda se essa música roseana comida
depois de botar no disfarçado este não
agenda a gente é longe e depois ficava
olhando pra los outra vez a pessoa comer
tudo meu é o melhor
ela não é ruim aí planta para instruir
colega no cras foco é que não se nutre
tinha um evento que parava qualquer
escola importa com a escola ea escola de
rico só escolhe pobre o nome do evento
era interclasse o respeito de uma sala
era conquistado entanto a escola do item
ser uniformizado todo mundo em família
as camisinhas né
cansado tem que botar cada um e chuteira
da mesa não cobra combinada num jardim
ao número 7 não sabe nem jogar mal o pai
é óbvio tem uniforme tem aqui cara kombi
nosso time com a amarela amanhã todo
mundo com um golo de com amarelo não
tinha chegam com a camisa maior chegou
com a câmera de político amarelo chegou
com abadá amarelo chega outro camisa
amarela mãe que estava na 8ª o sábado
quem eu sou pé descalço m3 de carro não
tem uma religião que não descalço quarta
jogando descalça ramo chabon um pedaço
de talca e substituir sai entre um cara
sem dedo que já perdeu o dedo
interclasse passado agora porque eu
tenho que concordar que o inter classe
da escola de rico é justo porque os
meninos estão todos na mesma faixa
etária então tudo bem tamanho na escola
pode ser que ganhou interclasse é a 4ª
ea 5ª série porque sempre tive essas
casas têm acordos minho que perderam
quatro ano a empatar no primeiro ano ea
praga marcar na quinta do seival
escalação do time só aqui um metro e
quarenta desnutrido 12 anos joão mede 45
13 anos no tribunal está o cleiton um
metro e noventa e cinco 21 anos pedreiro
celso do met 10.002 a trabalhar por na
por dan serraria carrega a tora de
madeira anos nas costas para embarcar
por tatuagens e cicatrizes de faca nos
peitos mac incluindo os caba desses
brigas corre tem briga com a bola para a
alta que é uma coisa meio de ano estão
brincando vai para a diretoria é a mesma
coisa e mais o beijo tanque neste ano
agora é obrigatória foi em 2036 já te
passar organiza desde aquela briga mas
nem fala e agora você vai ficar sem o
seu ex-banco spaceshipone 17 por onde
agentes em severo judite descobre o
problema mas a briga na sala começa a
discutir e cheguei partiu pra cima você
for parcial que brigar brigar lá fora
na minha ano aí eles vão lá fora
obrigado professor dentro da sala que o
valor de x cá lá fora só nessa levada de
que brigava abrigá lá fora já são 10 na
sala para fazer a torcer que brilha de
pobre sem torcida na briga o sol brilha
na escola do povo só tem uma regra é
essa aqui no méxico não deixa só dois é
só dois que é pra ninguém tem fernanda
abreu que valeu o deixa saldo no méxico
deixou doido só votar só ficou fora é só
a professora andréia o valor de x ou
separava prestar atenção só conhece o
valor diz aí começa a incomodar e se é
para que o valor não dá para o fã para
isso aí é bom parar agora a sala da
escola henrique é bonito a explicação da
escola henrique é tudo branco e as
cadeiras são bonitinhos e senta na
cadeira e tem aquela mesinha na frente
sempre botar os livre embaixo e pra quem
escolhe o povo já pinta de outros cuja
batom azul já button amarelo porque se
você vota branco
abre espaço para as crianças risca mais
ainda escolas cadeira por das cadeiras
que você senta e tem um braço aqui você
escrever e se escreve aqui não apoia
esse lado aí você me pergunta mas com
que os alunos de escolas públicas são os
mais aprovados em universidades e em
faculdades de todo o brasil é porque a
porrada não dá para dormir em cima dela
tá cansado trabalho noite todinha vai
pra escola ponta-cabeça tê las e deixa
cair no doi respeito porque não dá pra
coisa eo negócio escrever só do lado
direito os canhotos que se todas você
onde estiver pela rua encontrar um cara
desse jeito aqui ó irã da torre de lado
as incertezas um canhoto que escrever
destinado a quinta melhor escola requer
condicionada isso é que é legal a
continuar a linha só de bonze alan tal
porque acaba energia ganha nem percebe
que está frio tá gostoso na escola pode
já ter reclamado que não sei de quem foi
a ideia tem quem foi que achou seguro
tem ventilador dentro de sala de aula e
preto é um negócio roda em cima então
acho que ele vai jogar coisa nele acho
que vai rolar caneta não vai jogar lápis
vai jogar bolinha de papel que um dia
fosse para jogar alguém que se eu
tivesse força pegava meu show estava
cimentada tá na minha sala tinha
inventado fazer esse ano isso era bom
porque quando acaba a energia e
sinalizar o pajero que ela estava
escrevendo aqui botar lá a água energia
am era desculpa para pedir a professora
vai encerrar a a energia acabou a
energia é doido ou calorzão e dá não dá
não dá não possui essa aula e oita não é
professor e ir pra casa também do dia
embora esse equador é um perigo que
chamará a acim morgan é o dia que
cheguei a cair na cabeça de alguém é
interessante porque passava de ano ea
outra sala mas todo dia eu ia lá na
minha sala goiás e bahia caiu na cabeça
de alguém você que vai cair certeza esse
aqui é matar um certeza não será a
estratégia do governo para controle
populacional deixar algum resultado cai
na escola e matar algumas crianças seu
recado vai colocar na minha cabeça ficar
puto eu ia ficar pulou para chegarmos a
encontrar com as pessoas massa não eu
comemorei na guerra estava na guerra 7
nos respeitar e defender meu melhor me
está atrás de mim e do meu comeu morreu
era bombeiro das torres gêmeas sabem 146
pessoas morreu to
rio o movimento foi herói e tom é o
carro é a família tomou eu como falar ou
morriam tava mal já era e cheirar não
tinha como não salvar não morreu como de
cuxá vida a vida quando quer matar na
mata por um negócio no tempo em que não
tem importância de tiro essa escolha não
morri qualquer correto pela guerra tinha
bombeamento a dor várias coisas não
basta uma auditoria paulo no rio de arno
pronto foi isso criar no chassi nerd não
houve pela dor que o banheiro povo a
escola henrique massa que ele pinta e
cheio de banheiro e tal hora do banho
comer tem cheiro do banheiro não contei
e canapí eu escolhi pobre - e
comunicações com a minha escola é assim
parece que alguém foi me já lá em morreu
ele ficou lá podre passei sempre tem um
banheiro nem a porta do banheiro 60
transporte dos cágados em meu amigo
nessas porta tua 2 do mar no tanque x
vídeo é dito bi no mundo que tenha tanto
por equipe derrotou nas porta de
banheiro e escolhe povos cada desenho
para equipar cara expectação triângulo
aqui aqui aqui os cabelos sim pra fora e
botas cabelo que assim em tese os
príncipe - que não só não foi com esse
número porque não disse me ouvir o
pedido do king kong
a idéia é buscar com as roma maior do
mundo desde o cara desta manhã a rolar é
desse tamanho que ele é que o cara está
aqui a mulher tá aqui ea roda ele
percorre daqui até aqui eu não sei qual
foi o filme alienígena que eles
assistiram à muita loucura nunca pensei
muito obrigado por ter se estivesse
vindo até aqui se você está aqui no
youtube não esquece você está carregando
outras coisas aqui clica primeiro e
gostei antes de sair do vídeo em qual
escola dessas você estudou totalmente
aqui embaixo esconde com a escola o
pobre vota lá no facebook ou porque esse
vídeo vídeo novo não esquece isso é
muito importante e clicar em curtir lá e
marcar os teus amigos lá nos comentários
no facebook estudaram na escola do rico
ou na escola do pobre no instagram cuja
fonte de divulgação está no twitter da
rtp você do mtst me ajudando muito muito
obrigado por ter sido até aqui é nóis
[Música]